- [Instructor] We're told that Adam flew
his remote controlled
drone off of a platform.
The function f models
the height of the drone
above the ground, in meters,
as a function of time, in
seconds, after takeoff.
So what they want us
to do is plot the point
on the graph of f that corresponds to each
of the following things.
So pause the video and
see if you can do that,
and, obviously, you can't
draw on your screen.
This is from an exercise on Khan Academy,
but you can visually look at it,
and even with your
finger, point to the part
of the graph of f that
represents each of these things.
All right, so the first thing here
is the height of the platform.
So the drone is at the
height of the platform
right when it takes off,
'cause it says Adam flew
his remote controlled drone
off of a platform.
So what is the time that he's taking off,
the drone, or the drone is taking off?
Well, that's going to
be at time t equals zero
right over here.
And what is the height of
the drone at that moment?
It is 60 meters.
So that must be the
height of the platform.
So that point right over there tells us
the height of the platform.
And if they asked us what the
height of the platform is,
it would be 60 meters.
The next one is the
drone's maximum height.
So then as time goes on,
we can see the drone starts going
to a higher and higher and higher height,
gets as high as 80 meters.
And then it starts going down.
So it looks like 80
meters, at time 10 seconds,
the drone hits a maximum
height of 80 meters.
And then last but not least,
they say the time when the
drone landed on the ground.
Now, we can assume that the ground
is when the height of the
drone is at zero meters,
and we can see that that
happens right over here.
And that happens at time
t equals 30 seconds.
And so we've just marked it off,
and I know what some of
you all are thinking.
Wait, there's another time
where the drone's height is at zero,
and that's right over here.
That's at negative 10 seconds.
Couldn't we say that that's also a time
when the drone landed on the ground?
And this is a important point to realize,
because if we're really trying
to model the drone's behavior
from time t equals zero,
if t equals zero is
right when you take off
all the way to it lands,
then this parabola that we're
showing right over here,
it actually, we would probably want
to restrict its domain to positive times.
And so this negative time
region right over here
really doesn't make a lot of sense.
We should probably consider
the non-negative values
of time when we're trying to think
about these different thins.